let's just do a ton of more examples
just that we make sure that we're
getting this trig function thing down
well so let's construct ourselves some
right triangles
let's construct ourselves some right
triangles and i want to be very clear
the way i've defined it so far this will
only work in right triangles so if
you're trying to find the trig functions
of angles that aren't part of right
triangles we're going to see that we're
going to construct right triangles but
let's just focus on the right triangles
for now so let's say that i have a
triangle where let's say this length
down here is 7 and let's say the length
of this side up here let's say that that
is 4 and let's figure out what the
hypotenuse over here is going to be so
we know let's call the hypotenuse
h we know that h squared is going to be
equal to
7 squared plus 4 squared we know that
from the pythagorean theorem that the
hypotenuse squared is equal to the
square of each of the the sum of the
squares of the other two sides h squared
is equal to 7 squared plus 4 squared so
this is equal to 49
plus
16
49 plus 16. see 49 plus 10 is 59 plus 6
is
65 it is 65. so this h squared
let me write h squared
it's a different shade of yellow so we
have h squared is equal to
65. i do that right 49 plus 10 is 59
plus another 6 is 65 or we could say
that h is equal to if we take the square
root of both sides
square root square root of 65 and we
really can't simplify this at all this
is 13 this is the same thing as 13 times
5 both of those are not perfect squares
and they're both prime so you can't
simplify this anymore so this is equal
to the square root of 65. now let's find
the trig
let's find the trig functions for this
angle up here let's call that angle up
there theta
so whenever you do it you always want to
write down at least for me it works out
to write down sohcahtoa
so
i have these vague memories of my
trigonometry teacher maybe i read it in
some book i don't know you know some
about some type of indian princess name
sulkator or whatever but it's a very
useful mnemonic so we can apply so let's
find
let's say we wanted to find the cosine
we want to find the cosine of our angle
we want to find the cosine of our angle
you say sohcahtoa so the ka
tells us what to do with cosine
the part tells us that cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse cosine is equal
to adjacent over hypotenuse so let's
over here look over here to theta what
side is adjacent well we know that the
hypotenuse we know that the hypotenuse
is this side over here so it can't be
that side the only other side that's
kind of adjacent to it that isn't the
hypotenuse is this 4.
so the adjacent side over here that side
is it's literally right next to the
angle it's one of the sides that kind of
forms the angle it's 4 over the
hypotenuse the hypotenuse we already
know is square root of 65 so it's 4
over the square root of 65. and
sometimes people want you to rationalize
the denominator which means they don't
like to have an irrational number in the
denominator like the square root of 65
and if they if you want to rewrite this
without a irrational number in the
denominator you can multiply the
numerator and the denominator by square
root of 65. this clearly will not change
the number because we're multiplying it
by something over itself so we're
multiplying the number by 1 that won't
change the number but at least it gets
rid of the irrational number in the
denominator so the numerator becomes
4 times the square root of 65 and the
denominator square root of 65 times
square root of 65 is just going to be
65. we didn't get rid of the irrational
number it's still there but it's now in
the numerator
now let's do the other trig functions
or at least the other core trig
functions we'll learn in the future that
there's actually a ton of them but
they're all derived from these so let's
think about what the sine of theta is
once again go to sohcahtoa the so tells
us what to do with sine sine is opposite
over hypotenuse
sine
is equal to opposite over hypotenuse
sine is opposite over hypotenuse so for
this angle what side is opposite well
you just go opposite it what it opens
into it's opposite the seven
so the opposite side is the seven this
is right here that is the opposite side
and then the hypotenuse it's opposite
over hypotenuse the hypotenuse is the
square root of 65
square root of 65. and once again if we
wanted to rationalize this we could
multiply it times the square root of 65
over the square root of 65 in the
numerator we'll get 7 square roots of 65
and in the denominator we will get just
65 again
now let's do
tangent let us do tangent
so if i asked you the tangent
of the tangent of theta once again go
back to sohcah toa the torah part tells
us what to do with tangent it tells us
it tells us that tangent
is equal to opposite over adjacent is
equal to opposite
over
opposite over adjacent
so for this angle what is opposite we've
already figured it out it's seven it
opens into the seven it's opposite the
seven
so it's seven
over what side is adjacent well this
four is adjacent this four is adjacent
so the adjacent side is four so it's 7
over 4. and we're done we figured out
all of the trig ratios for theta let's
do another one
let's do another one i'll make a little
bit concrete because right now we've
been saying oh what's tangent of x
what's tangent of theta let's make it a
little bit more concrete
let's say
let's say let me draw another right
triangle
there's another right triangle here
everything we're dealing with these are
going to be right triangles
let's say the hypotenuse has length 4
let's say that this side over here has
length 2
and let's say that this length over here
is going to be 2 times the square root
of 3. we can verify that this works if
you have this side squared so you have
let me write it down 2 times the square
root of 3 squared
plus 2 squared is equal to what this is
2 is going to be 4 times 3
4 times 3 plus 4 and this is going to be
equal to 12 plus 4 is equal to 16 and 16
is indeed 4 squared so this does equal 4
squared it does equal 4 squared it
satisfies the pythagorean theorem and if
you remember some of your work from 30
60 90 triangles that you might have
learned in geometry you might recognize
that this is a 30-60-90 triangle this
right here is our right angle i should
have drawn it from the get-go to show
that this is a right triangle this angle
right over here is our 30 degree angle
and then this angle up here this angle
up here is a 60 degree angle and it's a
30 60 90 because the side opposite the
30 degrees is half the hypotenuse and
then the side opposite the 60 degrees is
a square root of 3 times the other side
that's not the hypotenuse so with that
said we're not going to this isn't
supposed to be a review of 30 60 90
triangles although i just did it let's
actually find the trig ratios for the
different angles
so if i were to ask you or if anyone
were to ask you what is
what is the sine of 30 degrees
and remember
30 degrees is one of the angles in this
triangle but it would apply whenever you
have a 30 degree angle and you're
dealing with a right triangle we'll have
broader definitions in the future but if
you say sine of 30 degrees hey this
angle right over here is 30 degrees so i
can use this right triangle
and we just have to remember sohcahtoa
let me rewrite it so
toa
sine tells us so tells us what to do
with sine sine is opposite over
hypotenuse sine of 30 degrees is the
opposite side that is the opposite side
which is two
over the hypotenuse the hypotenuse here
is four it is two-fourths which is the
same thing as one-half sine of 30
degrees you'll see is always going to be
equal to one half
now what is the cosine
what is the cosine of 30 degrees once
again go back to sohcahtoa the tells us
what to do with cosine cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse so if we're
looking at the 30 degree angle it's the
adjacent this right over here is
adjacent it's right next to it it's not
the hypotenuse it's the adjacent over
the hypotenuse so it's two
square roots of three
adjacent
over
over the hypotenuse over four
or if we simplify that we divide the
numerator and the denominator by two
it's the square root of three
over two finally let's do the tangent
the tangent
of
30 degrees
we go back to soca toa soka toa toa
tells us what to do with tangent it's
opposite over adjacent we go to the 30
degree angle because that's what we care
about tangent of 30 tangent of 30
opposite is 2
opposite is 2 and the adjacent is 2
squares of 3. it's right next to it it's
adjacent to it adjacent means next to so
2 square roots of 3 so this is equal to
the 2s cancel out 1 over the square root
of 3 or we can multiply the numerator
and the denominator by the square root
of 3. so we have square root of 3 over
square root of 3 and so this is going to
be equal to the numerator square root of
3 and then the denominator right over
here is just going to be 3. so that's
we've rationalized it square root of 3
over 3. fair enough now let's use the
same triangle to figure out the trig
ratios for the 60 degrees since we've
already drawn it
so what is
what is the sine of the 60 degrees i
think you're hopefully getting the hang
of it now
sine is opposite over adjacent so from
the sohcahtoa for the 60 degree angle
what side is opposite
well it opens out into the two squares
of three so the opposite side is two
squares of three
and from the 60 degree angle the j or
sorry it's opposite over hypotenuse
don't want to confuse you so it's
opposite over hypotenuse so it's 2
square roots of 3 over 4 4 is the
hypotenuse so it is equal to this
simplifies to square root of 3
over 2.
what is the cosine of 60 degrees cosine
of 60 degrees
so remember so katoa cosine is adjacent
over hypotenuse
adjacent is the two side it's right next
to the 60 degree angle so it's two
over the hypotenuse which is four
so this is equal to
one half and then finally what is the
tangent
what is the tangent of 60 degrees well
tangent soka toa tangent is opposite
over adjacent
opposite the 60 degrees is two squares
of three
two square roots of three and adjacent
to that adjacent to that
is 2 adjacent to 60 degrees is 2. so
it's opposite over adjacent 2 square
roots of 3 over 2
which is just equal to the square root
of 3. and i just want to you know look
how these are related the sine of 30
degrees is the same thing as the cosine
of 60 degrees the cosine of 30 degrees
is the same thing as the sine of 60
degrees and then these guys are the
inverse of each other i think if you
think of a little bit about this
triangle it'll start to make sense why
we'll keep extending this and give you a
lot more practice in the next few videos